[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's time to
talk about Android Things.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'm standing here
with Vince, a product
manager on Android Things.
VINCE WU: Hi.
How you doing?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
How you doing, man?
VINCE WU: Good.
Very good.
It's a big moment for us today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
let's talk about that.
There was an announcement.
What was it?
VINCE WU: Android Things 1.0.
So we're ready.
We're ready for business.
We've been working on
this for quite a while,
and now we're
available for people
to make commercial products.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is that
what it means to come out
of developer preview?
VINCE WU: Oh, yes.
So we have a full solution
for going from prototype
all the way to production.
So if you take one of our
supported hardware modules,
you can build very
interesting stuff.
And in fact, we've
actually put it
through its paces,
tried it out for real
with a couple of
large and small OEMs.
And we have built
really cool products.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
talk about that.
This whole prototype
to production thing,
that full spectrum is relatively
unique in the field of IoT,
right?
VINCE WU: Oh, yes.
If we're talking about
prototyping on microcontroller,
microprocessor SoCs, you've
got tons of solutions
out there to do that.
But those solutions don't take
you to production, let alone
commercial launch.
So that's what's different
with our solution.
The other thing is long-term
guaranteed support.
So we offer security
patches and stability fixes
for the long-term.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Now, behind us is actually
a demonstration, really,
of prototype to production.
Can you tell me a little bit
about what's right there?
VINCE WU: Oh, yes.
Oh, wow, this was a really,
really fun project for us.
So at the time,
a lot of partners
were interested in
building a new product
category called smart displays.
And they want to do
this really quickly.
And they thought that
we could help them out.
This was really fun,
because we started out
with literally a Lego demo.
And this is exactly what
we showed the partners.
What's in there is
our system module,
the solution with
Android Things running.
And we got this up and running
in just a couple of weeks.
It was really, really fast.
It shows the power of
Android and the flexibility
of the platform.
What they were
really interested,
also, was they were
expecting that this
would be a product that
would be updated a lot.
Because it's a new
product category,
they weren't sure how the
users would react to it.
So there's a lot of A/B
testing, putting people
into different groups.
And the app for Android Things
solution helped them do that.
And as you can see
through here, it
went from literally Lego
prototypes all the way
to the real product.
And we made this a little
bit hard on ourselves.
We didn't want to just
build one product,
but we wanted to build
multiple of them.
So we have products from
JPL, LG, and Lenovo.
And if you look inside,
what's really cool
is that they all use the
same system module, which
allows us to scale quickly
and go to production really,
really fast.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And you've
got some other cool stuff
in the sandbox that you can play
with built on Android Things.
And I think one of my
favorites is these flowers that
are using TensorFlow Lite.
Can you tell me how they work?
VINCE WU: Oh, yeah.
So this is, of
course, serious stuff
with real stuff on shelves.
But we also wanted to inspire
the developer community,
and so we built
a bunch of demos,
just maybe a little
bit whimsical,
but it does showcase
the technology.
So for example, we
have ML flowers.
It's running machine
learning on-device,
so it's totally offline.
None of it goes to the cloud.
It does detection of the facial
expressions-- so happy, sad.
It also detects your face,
so it follows you around.
We also have ones detecting
handwriting, et cetera.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
VINCE WU: It's a cool time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And can you
tell me a little bit more
about the technology
behind that, TensorFlow
running on the device?
VINCE WU: Oh, yes.
So all of it is
running on-device.
So you must have heard
the earlier announcement
around Firebase ML Kit.
So all of that stuff
works on Android Things,
as it does on
Android, of course.
For the demos that we built,
we took some of the existing
models that we had
in Google Research,
and we put them
onto the devices.
And it basically just works.
There's quite a few models
to play around with.
The most obvious one, of
course, is photo detection.
We showed that last year.
What's different this year
is that it's not just photos,
but it's actually live video.
So it's all in real time,
taking a video of you,
and detecting the
facial expressions,
tracking your
face, and all that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Vince, if you want to get
started with Android Things,
where do you go?
VINCE WU: Go to
androidthings.withgoogle.com.
You'll get everything there.
And if you're at I/O,
go pick yourself a kit,
and let's go build
some hardware.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you, so much.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is "I/O Live."
[MUSIC PLAYING]